Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with a Republican congressional candidate
named Darlene Sofer, and I think this is going
to be very, very interesting for our audience.
Darlene is a small business owner and is running
for Congress in Florida's 22nd District.
Darlene, I really appreciate you coming on
today.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
David, thank you for having me.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: And it's, you know, I'm always
interested in learning more about different
candidates, their ideas, whether there might
be, you know, my audience is on the left.
And it's always interesting to see where there
might be opportunities to sort of bridge divides
and work together and all of these different
types of things.
So let's kind of contextualize your candidacy
a little bit if I understand correctly.
Michael Flynn and Roger Stone have both endorsed
you.
Is that correct?
Speaker 2: That's correct.
Speaker 1: And a few hours before our interview,
you posted a picture of yourself with the
with the former President Donald Trump and
and you said it was wonderful to meet my president
just as a sort of like gut check, right?
Who's the current president of the United
States?
Speaker 2: I don't know.
That's debatable.
Some people feel that we had a stolen election
and that's an illegitimate president currently
serving.
Know I have my own thoughts on that.
But if you if you look back in the last one
year and several months, where are we as a
country?
I mean, we went from being energy independent
to now purchasing oil from Russia and negotiating
oil with Venezuela.
We went from having very low inflation to
having very high inflation.
We got back into the Paris accord, even though
we are very responsibly a global citizen on
our energy consumption.
Well, let's get to that.
Speaker 1: But Darlene, I want to hold you
to who's the current president.
Speaker 2: Well, I don't believe that the
current president is is a legitimate president,
and we'll leave it at that.
Speaker 1: Is Joe Biden currently the president?
Even if you think he's illegitimate, is he
the president?
Speaker 2: I don't believe he is.
I don't believe that is the current legitimate
president.
Speaker 1: And what is the current legitimate
president?
Speaker 2: I don't I don't believe we have
a current legitimate president.
Speaker 1: Wow.
So in a sense, there's no president of the
U.S. right now.
Speaker 2: I guess that's your interpretation
of what I said, but OK.
Speaker 1: Well, you tell me, I mean, is there
a president right now, I guess?
Speaker 2: Well, I'd rather not answer that.
How is that?
Because I kind of feel like you're leading
down an area of controversy that we don't
have to go.
Speaker 1: OK, interesting.
Let's talk about the energy independence thing
just to pick one thing.
And so this, I think, will give my audience
a lot of kind of insights into your into your
campaign.
The United States in 2020, which was Donald
Trump's last year in office, produced as much
oil as we used.
And I think that's what you're signaling when
you talk about being energy independent.
We used a certain amount of oil and we produced
an amount that matched that.
And in 2021, the same thing happened.
We produced as much oil as we used.
So can you tell me on what basis you say that
we are no longer energy independent under
Joe Biden?
Speaker 2: Well, actually, if you look at
the graph of how much oil we've purchased
from Russia, it's significantly more than
what we were producing for ourselves.
I mean, that graph was well published, and
I'm happy to email that to you.
But that is an inaccurate statement that you
just shared.
It doesn't matter how much oil we consume,
we can either produce our own oil and build
back our reserves, which is what President
Trump did or deplete our oil reserves and
start purchasing oil from other countries,
which is evident in the price of gas today.
I mean, it was under $2 a gallon a year and
three months ago.
And what are we now?
Four dollars, five dollars in some cases,
six or seven dollars?
That is your evidence.
Speaker 1: Let's get back to gas prices and
I want to really with you.
I love the clarity of the conversation where
let's let's agree to first talk oil and then
we'll talk gas.
So did you know that the U.S. for decades
has purchased oil from foreign countries?
So under Trump, even though we produced as
much oil as we used some of the oil we produce,
we export.
And to make up for that, we import some oil.
And under both Trump and Biden, we imported
oil from Russia.
Did you know that?
Speaker 2: Did you know that in the last 20
years, we had presidents in the United States
that did not focus on energy independence
and producing our our own oil and offshore
those opportunities to other countries?
Did you know that?
Speaker 1: Well, but that's not an answer
to my question.
Speaker 2: That is an answer, because it's
not about the Trump presidency.
What Trump did was create energy independence
to the point where we were exporting oil.
OK, that's not what happened in previous presidential
administrations.
Speaker 1: But you criticized Joe Biden for
Speaker 2: importing oil from Russia from
an administration and lies to the Clinton
administration and allies to the Bush administration.
It was both Democrat and Republican presidents
that did not look out for the interests of
American families, and what Trump did was
put American families first.
We have the capability to farm our own reserves
from gas, coal and gas.
Speaker 1: But Darlene, if we
Speaker 2: can,
Speaker 1: if we can darlin, I really want
to take it one issue at a time.
I want to take it one issue at a time.
Where will you concede that in both 2020 and
2021, U.S. oil production exceeded consumption?
Will you concede that?
And then we'll get to the disagreement.
Will you concede
Speaker 2: that actually, it's not a concession
we did produce more or the oil than we consume,
but that's because we were able to export
it and actually earn income back to the Treasury
on what we exported.
Now we're no longer in an exportation phase.
We are purchasing oil from other countries
because we're not producing enough oil.
Speaker 1: Let's see.
I don't want to belabor it, but at the same
time, I want to make sure my audience understands
where where we're disagreeing in both 2020
and 2021.
Let's see if we can even break it down.
More simply, darlin.
In 2020, the U.S. used a certain amount of
oil.
Will you will you agree that we used oil in
2020?
Speaker 2: Of course we used oil.
Speaker 1: Will you agree?
We used oil in 2021?
Speaker 2: We didn't use oil in 2021.
Good.
Speaker 1: Will you agree that in both 2020
and 2021, forget for a second about exports.
We produced more oil than we used in 2020
and 2021.
Are we OK on that?
Right.
But but hold on just what we get to it.
We'll get to it.
But we agree so far.
Right?
OK.
In both 2020 and 2021, we exported some oil,
right?
Yes.
And in 2020 and 2021, we imported some oil
from Russia.
Speaker 2: We imported very little oil.
I don't have the chart in front of me, but
Speaker 1: we did import some right right,
Speaker 2: and we had to we had to produce
more oil because our oil reserves were depleted
under the Obama administration.
Trump put back our oil reserves during his
administration.
Would you agree to that?
Speaker 1: No, I don't agree to that.
But let's but let's get to that.
We'll get to the disagreement.
So so far, our leads is great because we're
really going through the nuts and bolts.
We both agree that in 2020 and 2021, the US
produced more oil than we used, and we agree
that in 2020 and 2021 we exported some oil
and we agree that in 20 and 21, we imported
some oil from Russia.
So what's the big criticism of what Biden
did in 2001?
It sounds like it was exactly the same thing.
Speaker 2: Well, actually, we didn't purchase
oil to the extent in twenty twenty one, like
we did in twenty twenty or twenty nineteen.
Oh, so
Speaker 1: Biden was more independent.
He didn't purchases much
Speaker 2: purchased oil in twenty twenty
one that we did not as a country purchase
in twenty twenty twenty nineteen twenty eighteen
and twenty seven.
Oh, he purchased more than four years under
Trump's administration.
We did not purchase the oil from Russia to
the extent of what Biden has done.
Got it?
Twenty one.
OK.
That is fact.
Speaker 1: OK.
All right.
Let's talk a little about gas prices.
Who's responsible for high global gas prices
right now?
Speaker 2: What was responsible for a high
global gas prices?
If we are producing our own oil, we can control
the market behind the prices.
Speaker 1: Mm-Hmm.
Speaker 2: That's Economics 101.
Speaker 1: OK.
But so right now, would you agree that gas
prices are high in the United States?
Speaker 2: They are extremely high.
Okay, brother is a truck driver with his own
rig.
OK?
Over a thousand dollars to fill his truck
with gas.
OK, what does that equate to?
He's going to have a higher cost for logistics
to transport goods.
Got it.
That's going to translate to higher prices
of cost of goods sold, absolutely higher prices
of retail prices.
And then if you're purchasing something that
costs more today than it did yesterday, then
you're paying higher sales tax for it.
Absolutely.
At the end of the day, we are all paying for
more based on the decisions of the current
administration.
Speaker 1: Let's, but let's let's wait.
So we agree gas prices are high in the US.
Do you agree gas prices are high in France
right now?
Speaker 2: Well, France doesn't produce their
own oil, but
Speaker 1: that wasn't my question, Darlene,
is do you agree that gas prices are high in
France,
Speaker 2: France or they're not producing
oil?
They're at the mercy of supply and demand
of countries.
They can purchase oil fine.
Speaker 1: But my question is, do you agree
gas prices are high in France right now?
Speaker 2: They're high everywhere, all over
the world, beautiful.
Speaker 1: So we can even skip that part.
Speaker 2: OK?
Speaker 1: Is Joe Biden responsible for that?
Speaker 2: Absolutely 100 percent.
How?
Why did he stop production of the Keystone
pipeline?
Why are we not producing the same level of
oil that we did during the Trump administration?
OK.
Know excuse on why we can't produce our own
oil.
Speaker 1: Hold on a second, though, Darlene.
Let's take it a step at a time now because
we want to be clear.
Keystone XL Pipeline.
You know that Keystone XL phase for, well,
I guess let's back up.
Keystone XL is four phases, right?
Three of the phases have been up and running
for years.
The fourth is what we're now talking about.
Agree so far, right?
Speaker 2: That was ten thousand
Speaker 1: jobs, but hold on a second.
Hold on.
I'm sorry.
Wait a sec, darling.
Wait a second.
Okay.
Do you agree that phase four of Keystone XL
was not active when Trump was president?
Trump was.
Trump wanted to do construction, but it wasn't
active?
Speaker 2: No, of course, they weren't producing
oil.
Beautiful, flowing the oil through that pipeline.
Beautiful.
Speaker 1: Agreed 100 percent.
Do you agree that the pipeline is a method
of transporting oil, not producing it?
Speaker 2: That is a method of transporting
oil, but that also reduces the cost of supply
and demand as well.
How you have to factor that in?
What do you mean?
How if they can get the oil to certain markets
within the United States more efficiently?
Yeah, that's going to reduce the cost of production
and transporting.
Correct.
Speaker 1: Your Economics 101 is a big thing
for you, right?
We're talking.
Do you know how much global oil production
would go up if Keystone XL Phase four was
completed?
Speaker 2: How much it would go up in what
respect?
Give an example.
Speaker 1: Percentage wise, so if right now
we are what we would call 100 per right now,
the status quo is 100 percent right.
If Keystone XL Phase four goes live, how much
does oil production globally go up?
Speaker 2: I don't have the answer to that.
It's one percent.
Why would you why?
Well, I don't know if that's your fact, and
I don't think that fact is accurate.
Speaker 1: No facts are facts.
Facts are not opinions.
A fact is a fact that would go up one percent.
Speaker 2: Show me the evidence behind that
fact because I have not heard that it would
only be one percent.
I actually think that's radical liberal facts,
and people assume that those are facts.
So share with us, what is your facts behind?
It's only been one percent.
Speaker 1: So everybody from everybody from
the NRDC to.
I mean, it's, you know, whoever you want to
say it.
We're talking about a one percent increase
globally that would make a gas price difference.
You know that Darleen Economics, you know,
one,
Speaker 2: actually, I don't believe in that
one percent.
I believe that's the narrative that they probably
want everyone to kind of run with.
OK.
So I find it hard to believe that a pipeline
would only produce one percent of the
Speaker 1: pipelines don't actually produce
anything.
They're just transport methods.
It would allow the transport of one percent
more oil.
Speaker 2: Right?
You just don't believe it.
Well, share share the facts with your audience.
Share with me, and then we can analyze that.
Speaker 1: Beautiful, beautiful, OK.
What do you think the top tax rate should
be?
Speaker 2: The top tax rate, actually, I believe
us citizens were double, triple and quadruple
taxed.
OK, so I think right now the federal the federal
tax is.
In the 33rd percentile, when you add everything
together, what do you
Speaker 1: mean, percentile?
Speaker 2: Well, when you're looking at how
you do your taxes, right?
Yeah, it's throughout 30 plus percent that
comes out of your income in terms of taxes,
state, federal, county, any local taxes when
you add all that up together.
Well, it depends
Speaker 1: what state you live in, how much
you make and a lot of things, right?
Speaker 2: Correct.
I was in accounting and finance major.
I did my taxes for many years.
This is a run about that bracket.
So you had Medicare tax, you had all the different
taxes, but that much.
And then on top of that, you have sales tax.
And then on top of that, you have gas tax.
And then, you know, if you smoke, there's
a cigaret tax.
And then when you die, there's taxes, everything.
There's taxes on everything, OK?
And then when you die, there's an estate taxes.
Thirty five percent
Speaker 1: if you have more than 10 and a
half million dollars.
Speaker 2: No.
Yes.
It's less than that.
Speaker 1: No, it's ten and a half million,
yeah.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
No, it's less than that.
Speaker 1: What do you think it is?
Speaker 2: Well, there's a death tax of like
if I if I die tomorrow before my son could
collect any assets, yeah, there's a death
tax.
Speaker 1: Did you know that that starts at
11:00?
That starts at about your first $11 million.
There's no federal estate tax.
Speaker 2: There's a death tax.
No.
Yes.
Where did you get that?
There's a death tax that everybody goes through
when you die and you leave your assets to
your ears, right?
That's the tax that is going to be assessed
by the government before your heirs got any
money.
Speaker 1: But this is one of the big This
is wild, Darlene.
You're a candidate, and it sounds like you
don't know that the first eleven point seven
million dollars of one's estate does it.
You won't.
You only pay tax after you leave eleven point
seven million to your heirs.
You didn't know that, did you?
Speaker 2: If it's eleven point seven, how
is it that my because I deal with seniors
all day long?
OK, OK, OK.
And I had a I had a client that only had two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and her
estate was hit with a death tax before her
children collected it.
So how did that happen with her?
Speaker 1: Maybe it was at the state level,
I don't know, but federally there's an eleven
point seven.
But hold on, but hold on.
There's a you can your first eleven point
seven million.
There's no tax federally
Speaker 2: right on the federal level.
OK, but you
Speaker 1: didn't know that two minutes ago.
Speaker 2: Right, right.
But that's on the federal level there.
So, Mike, I do with seniors all day long.
OK.
What I did for the last 11 years and I've
heard way too many.
In a matter of fact, this is the biggest concern
the seniors have brought to my attention that
they have to set up a trust which cost $3000,
typically to set up about twenty five hundred
to three thousand.
Yeah, so that they could try to protect their
assets and not be subject to the death tax
before they leave their children any money.
Speaker 1: Now, wouldn't it be the right thing
to do?
Is someone advising seniors to let them know
that their first eleven point seven million
are exempt?
Speaker 2: Well, I'm not a tax advisor, so
that's not up to me to share that information
with them.
I sell Medicare health insurance, so I'm not
going to give advice there, so it has nothing
to do with my life.
Speaker 1: I think that's responsible, Darlene.
But back to the first question.
Let's focus in on the federal tax rate because
every state has different tax rates, different
sales tax rates, etc.
Federally speaking, what do you think the
top tax rate should be?
Speaker 2: I know that there were some recommendations
where people said maybe we shouldn't have
any more than 14 or 15 percent across the
board.
OK.
I would love to see lower taxes.
I'm for less government and lower taxes, so
that's part of the Republican platform.
And I'd love to see everyone pay lower taxes.
I think that we should have a much more efficiently
run government.
I think a lot of the three letter agencies
of four letter agencies that we have on a
national level should be brought back down
to the state level.
I think there's a lot of duplication of efforts.
So when you look at those agencies and you
look at the number of employees employed by
those agencies and you eliminate that budget,
that would be a completely different financial
picture on how our government could be run
more efficiently.
Speaker 1: In terms of the tax rate, though,
you would like to see the top federal rate
go down to 14 percent.
Speaker 2: I would like to see it less.
Yes.
Speaker 1: OK.
And at what income would that top rate kick
in?
Speaker 2: I mean, if you think about it realistically,
you know, and I have different look, I grew
up poor, OK, I'm a true rags.
The success story.
I run a very successful company.
OK.
And I don't think it's easy for anyone to
live a very standard lifestyle if you're making
under one hundred thousand dollars a year.
I just think that it's really challenging
with how expensive rent is.
Sure, a mortgage is, I mean, and it's difficult
for any single income household to survive.
I mean, we're almost forced to have two incomes
coming into the home in order to survive.
So I would like to see the benchmark much
higher than that, maybe above two hundred
and fifty thousand, maybe even more, maybe
four hundred thousand.
I mean, I have some strategies that I would
like to implement.
And this is to your point, because I know
you want to stay on point, but it touches
on taxes.
OK, so now the average American person that
works a blue collar job or professional job,
and they're under that, you know, a couple
hundred thousand a year mark when they work
overtime, if they're an hourly rate person,
if they work overtime, why are they working
overtime?
They're working overtime to pay down their
bills, right?
Pay down their student debt.
They're they're working overtime to maybe
save money, to take their family on vacation.
I would like to see the overtime pay not be
taxed.
I would like to see the income part of it
still be counted when when you are looking
into getting a mortgage, for example, whether
they need to know what your income is in order
to qualify you for a mortgage.
So I still want the income to count towards
Social Security income.
Apply for a mortgage applying for a loan to
get a car?
Sure.
But the payroll taxes on the overtime pay,
I would like to see that eliminated.
Speaker 1: Darlene, that's a very interesting
idea.
That's a very interesting, I'll be honest.
It's the most interesting idea you've presented
so far, I would say.
And it's not one that I've heard before, but
that that's a very and I'm guessing that this
would be for people earning under a certain
amount, right?
We're really targeting workers here.
Speaker 2: Yeah, we're targeting workers that
are hourly pay.
But you know, if you think about it, if they
had that portion that wasn't taxed, that additional
income and revenue increases our overall spending.
To me, that would even improve the economy
that would appear to improve people's ability
to eliminate their debt, to try to get ahead
in a way.
So I mean, I would just would love to see
that idea implemented.
I also have other ideas with regards to reforming
Medicare and improving solvency because some
experts are predicting that Medicare is going
to be insolvent in about two to three years.
Speaker 1: That's such a big topic.
Let's not dove into that right now, but at
least that one idea you had.
That's a very interesting idea in the last
few minutes we have.
Q and on in 2019, you wrote a lot of Q and
on stuff on your Facebook page, you talked
about how Q inspired you to run for Congress
in 2020.
Talk to me about Q and on.
Have you taken a so-called Q and on oath?
Speaker 2: I didn't write a lot of Q1 on post.
That's inaccurate.
I have a lot of friends that are, you know,
they call themselves digital soldiers, OK?
And I actually said that they inspired me
to run for office because to me, I feel that,
you know, we as Americans, we need to learn
the truth and they say Q Q. And on oath, there
was no Q anon oath.
It's the oath to protect the Constitution
against enemies, foreign and domestic.
So how do they attach a Q conspiracy idea
behind taking the oath to defend your country?
Actually find that insulting?
It was General Flynn that asked everyone to
do that oath, and if you look at my oath because
I did do the oath, yeah.
I also asked for God's protection and blessings
over our country.
That was the end of my oath base, my so-called
oath.
Got it.
You know, I took that oath because, you know,
my fifth and sixth grandfathers fought in
the Revolutionary War in the War of 1812,
and my eighth great uncle is Benjamin Franklin.
Well, what did Benjamin Franklin do when he
signed the Declaration of Independence?
He said, We either hang together or we hang
separately, but we most assuredly will hang.
So that's where the term we where we go, one
we go all came from.
John F. Kennedy had that on his boat.
OK.
President John F. Kennedy had that saying
on his boat.
So why people are attributing that to a conspiracy?
That's lack of knowledge on everyone's part,
and they're running away with that.
Speaker 1: So in other words, so you are not
a believer in QAnon.
Speaker 2: I've never said I was.
That's all conspiracy related media trying
to bash an America first.
Speaker 1: Well, this is why I want to ask,
you write.
So you're saying you do not believe or subscribe
to QAnon?
Speaker 2: No, I have friends that do OK and
I support anybody trying to find the truth.
Speaker 1: Understood.
Understood that.
That's that I think is very, very important
to know.
OK, Darlene.
Listen, this has been incredibly illuminating
and I can't thank you enough.
I think we've had a number of disagreements.
You had the one very interesting idea there
about not nontaxable overtime hours.
Very, very interesting.
I can't tell you how much I appreciate you
spending some time with us today.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
I appreciate that too.
And I'd love to see the facts behind what
you shared.
One percent how that's going to add to the
oil supply.
I know that's inaccurate, but we'd love to
see the data on that when
Speaker 1: we publish this.
Speaker 2: Your sources are inaccurate and
you don't know.
So I'm going to look into a two or whatever
I find.
I'm going to send it to you, please.
Speaker 1: Darlene, it's been an unfettered
pleasure on our end.
All right.
Thank you so much.